Speaker 1: Hey, remember that our program does
depend on your support so that we can continue
doing what we do. And one of the best things as
my chair. I think that by the end of the show,
I actually may fall off the chair. The
chair is collapsing very, very rapidly.
What we need a new chair, and this is why
membership is so important. No, it's something
we did a little bit of a renovation, a little bit
of a cleanup of the studio over the weekend. And
clearly some some I believe Antifa might have
sabotaged my chair. We'll look into that. No,
in all seriousness, we do what we do and we
do it free of me having ten editors and and
executives telling me cover this or don't cover
that or perpetuate the big lie or whatever has
been going on on Fox News. We're free from all
of that because our primary source of funding is
people from the audience. As much as I love Jill
from North Dakota and Bob from Tennessee and all
of this. None of them are going to write to me and
convince me to do a story differently or whatever
the case may be. Right. And this is the sort of
point of spreading our support across as many
people as possible. We remain in control, not some
big corporation or executive. And to that end,
you can sign up at join Packman dot com.
It's really cheap. It's really simple.
We do an extra show every day for our members
and you can use the coupon code 24 starts now
to get yourself a discount off of the cost
of membership. Glenn Youngkin did a very,
very stupid thing. He agreed to do a town hall
on CNN, and it went so bad so quickly that I can
only imagine he and his staff afterwards said, Why
the hell did we do that? Let's look at a couple of
clips and remember the context of Glenn Youngkin
becoming governor of Virginia was that he ran
against critical race theory. He sort of ran like
an issues free anti-woke campaign. Critical race
theory wasn't even being taught in Virginia
schools, and yet it was enough for him to win.
So there was very little substance in getting
him to be governor. And there remains very,
very little substance in his explanations about
how he's running Virginia and why he's running
Virginia in that way. So at one moment during
the event, a student who identifies as a trans
man asked Glenn Youngkin, Listen, which bathroom
should I be using, in your view, in your view,
about all of these issues of trans and gender
and whatever? Now, I dare you to find an actual
answer from Glenn Youngkin in this video. Governor
Youngkin Your transgender model policies would.
Speaker 3: Require that students play on
the sports teams and use the restrooms
that correspond with their sex assigned at birth.
Look at me. I am a transgender man. Do you really
think that the girls in my high school would
feel comfortable sharing a restroom with me?
Speaker 2: So first of all, Nico, thank
you for again asking the question,
being here tonight and engaging in this
important discussion. I believe first,
when parents are engaged with their children,
then you can make good decisions together. And
I met your dad, and I'm glad that you're both
here together. That's really, really important.
Speaker 1: Thank you for being here. I'm
aware that your father is here. Okay,
great. But like, what bathroom should Nico use?
Speaker 2: I also think that there are lots of
students involved in this decision. And what's
what's most important is that we try very hard
to accommodate students. That's why I have said
many, many times, we just need extra bathrooms
in schools. We need gender neutral bathrooms. And
so people can use the bathroom that they, in fact,
are comfortable with. I think sports are very
clear, and I don't think it's controversial. I
don't think that biological boys should be playing
sports with biological girls. There's been decades
of efforts in order to gain opportunities
for women in sports, and it's just not fair.
And I think that's pretty that's that's
non-controversial and something that I
think is is pretty well understood.
Speaker 1: Now, here is Nico's
dad shaking his head at this.
Speaker 2: Again, I think these
are very difficult discussions and I am very,
very glad to see you and your dad here together.
Speaker 1: Right. It seems the big thing
is that Nico and Nico's dad are both there.
That seems to be the thing Glenn Youngkin most
wants to talk about. So let's talk about this,
okay? First of all, young Quinn says the priority
is that people should be comfortable. Well,
then Nico should be using the men's room,
Right? Because it's abundantly clear that
Nico would be most comfortable in the men's
room. Then he goes into this thing of, well,
the bathrooms should be gender neutral as as a
complete and total copout. Now, I don't disagree.
I think the gender neutral bathrooms are great.
This has been a thing in Europe for a very,
very long time. It's fine to do gender neutral,
neutral bathrooms, but Virginia has thousands
of public schools and they don't even have
money for extra pencils for teachers. Okay.
The idea that we're going to solve this in
Virginia by converting thousands of bathrooms
to gender neutral rather than actually dealing
head on which with with which bathroom Nico should
use is absolutely laughable. Now, I've said this
before, and this is a real practical question.
I don't know how many of you are familiar
with Blair White or Chaz Bono or Bono. Bono
I'm not sure, Chad, but the idea that what is
logical and what would make everybody the most,
quote, comfortable under their view is for
Blair White, who was born biologically male
to use a men's room today is wacky.
Just Google a picture of Blair White
on the same hand. On the other hand, on the same
token, the idea that Chaz Bono or Bono, who was
born biologically female as a trans man, should
today be using a women's room again, if we want to
use their paradigm about what's most comfortable
visually based on how people look, that's absurd.
So there's really a bigger issue here which
young man doesn't actually want to address.
And this was about how the entire town hall,
where there was another moment where Youngkin
was asked about his view about removing books for
school libraries, and he similarly dissembled and
talked around the issue and didn't then really
dig into what's actually at all at issue here.
Speaker 2: So my my whole approach to this
starts with parents and transparency to make sure
that parents know what's in the library
and parents understand what materials
are being used in the curriculum. And so
last year we were able to pass a bill in
a bipartisan basis that gave parents full
visibility into materials in the classroom.
Speaker 1: Now, understand this, this
mostly already exists. So even even
this is a distraction. Well, as a first step,
parents need to know what's in the library and
what's being taught in their kid's classes, but
what's preventing them from doing that? And I
know there are people who will say, well, yeah,
you know, it's hard to get out of kids. You have
you tried talking to a 12 year old. 12 year olds
don't want to talk to their parents. They won't
tell you that, maybe, But there is nothing that
prevents parents from going to the school library
and looking around or from emailing the teacher or
whatever the case may be. So this entire thing we
formalized that there's going to be transparency.
They're basically is unless there's a rare
situation going on or special circumstances,
there's transparency already. It's not
actually getting at the issue of banning books.
Speaker 2: And if those are sexually explicit
materials that aren't consistent with family
values, then a parent can request a replacement,
a replacement material into their child's
curriculum. See, I do believe that there's
moments where we have to make decisions about
what's age appropriate and what is appropriate.
And those are hard decisions, but we shouldn't
run away from them. We should engage in them. And
these are healthy discussions for us to have.
Speaker 1: What this, of course, ignores,
and in a way it's similar to the issue of
abortion. What it ignores is just because
decisions have to be made that may be difficult.
Books that are edge cases for an eight year old,
for example. Or does a. Pregnant woman want
to get an abortion just because there are
difficult decisions or even morally complex
or philosophically ambiguous or whatever.
The idea that it's the government that should
be making those decisions is being accepted
as a foregone conclusion by folks like Glenn
Youngkin and others who want to get involved
in curriculum. Well, if the decisions have to
be made on abortion, they should be made by
medical professionals as well as the impacted
individuals, in particular the pregnant woman.
If we're making decisions about books, then
shouldn't those decisions be made by teachers
and educators rather than by Glenn Youngkin
and whoever he parties in a partizan way,
deputize his, but they ignore that as a reality.
Speaker 2: What books should be in an elementary
school library? Should they have
explicit pictures in them or not?
Well, I don't think they're they should be there.
Speaker 1: But it's not really.
Glenn Youngkin area of expertise.
Speaker 2: And these are decisions that I think we
should take on as opposed to run away from. Yeah.
Speaker 1: And the problem is who he wants taking
it on. So all of this just babble, babble, babble.
And then one more interesting clip here where Jake
TAPPER actually gets into it with Youngkin
about how history should be taught in school.
Speaker 2: Exactly. Ask you about that,
which is kind of following up on what Brock
was asking because you're executive order
that ended the teaching of CRT said that it
would end the teaching of inherently divisive
concepts, including CRT. So other than CRT,
can you give us a specific example of
what is an inherently divisive concept?
Speaker 1: Well, no, I only ran against
CRT, Jake. I'm not informed about anything.
Speaker 2: Else that you think should not be
taught in Virginia schools. Yet the inherent the
inherently divisive concepts are taken directly
from the Civil Rights Act, and they're teaching
children that they're inherently biased or
racist because of their race or their sex
or their religion. They teach that a child is
guilty for sins of the past because of their
race or their religion or their sex. They teach
that a child is is oppressed or a victim because
of their race, their religion, or their sex.
Speaker 1: Now, remember that there's two parts
to this. One, even though I have my problems with
critical race theory and other critical theories,
doesn't mean that he's accurately representing
what they teach. That's number one.
And then number two, this wasn't being
taught in Virginia at all. The fact that
whether what he's saying
about CRT is accurate or not,
it wasn't being taught in Virginia schools.
Speaker 2: And, of course, we've seen this in
curriculum, you see. Critical race theory isn't
a class that's taught. It's something that is
it's a philosophy that's incorporated in the
curriculum. So and we saw it in Fairfax County
with privilege bingo and games like this,
but we also saw it in teacher training and
professional development in recommended books.
Speaker 1: And this is how they are now
sliding around. The fact that this isn't
being taught, which is by saying, well,
it's being implicitly integrated as a philosophy.
And of course there are dozens of witnesses that
have said that is absolutely not the case and
it is not what is going on in Virginia schools.
So you have to understand, when you build your
campaign on nothing, you end up if you ever do a
town hall confronted with the reality that there
is no there there and you're completely unable
to substantively actually talk about anything.
And that's the way this entire town hall went.
I would say check out the entire thing. But
quite frankly, I don't think it's worth it,
but not a particularly good performance by
Glenn Youngkin. And even though his name is
being tossed around as a possible presidential
contender, it's not looking really, really good.